une situation fragile mais encore sous
contrôle c'est par ces mots que l'on
peut résumer la position du gouvernement
face à la crise sanitaire
alors que la progression des différents
variant continue d'inquiéter les
autorités
emmanuel macron écarte pour le moment
l'idée d'un confinement à l'issue du
conseil de défense ce mercredi le mot
d'ordre reste le même une surveillance
accrue pour adapter la stratégie si
nécessaire nous sommes aujourd'hui
engagés dans une mobilisation qui est
une mobilisation nationale pour éviter
un recond finement j'ai dit à l'instant
que faudrait toujours les mesures
nécessaires quand elles sont nécessaires
pour protéger notre système de santé
pour protéger l'hôpital et pour protéger
la santé des français mais vous savez le
confinement pour nous est une mesure
ultime recours
quand nous avons tout essayé est ce que
nous portons aujourd'hui collectivement
c'est une mobilisation nationale
supplémentaires pour tenir ensemble face
à l'épidémie
et pour faire reculer l'épidémie et ça c
est entre nos mains
a tous je le disais à l'instant avec les
gestes barrière avec le recours au
télétravail et avec les politiques est
menée par le gouvernement notamment sur
le tester alertés à protéger pour lutter
contre l'épidémie de kovy 19 l'exécutif
mis sur une vaccination massive de la
population
emmanuel macron a notamment annoncé ce
mardi que tous les adultes pourront se
faire vacciner avant la fin de l'été
pour y parvenir
la france pourrait même se tourner vers
la russie
après la publication de l'étude de la
revue scientifique the lancet tu
affirmes en l'efficacité de spoutnik v
le gouvernement ne ferme pas la porte à
l'utilisation du vaccin russe 6 tout
niké validé homologué par l'agencé
européenne du médicament et en france
par la haute autorité de santé il n'y a
aucun blocage pour qu'il soit diffusé
s'il correspond aux normes scientifiques
et aux exigences de robustesse et de
contrôle qui s'impose en europe
en attendant le point sur la situation
sanitaire effectué ce jeudi par jean
castex
un effort est une nouvelle fois demandé
aux français
à quelques jours des premiers départs en
vacances l'exécutif a rappelé la
nécessité du respect des restrictions
sanitaires et prolongé l'interdiction
des remontées mécaniques dans les
stations de ski jusqu'à nouvel ordre